Let's consider how we can use this
same approach now for stock data.
This is one of our pandas Data Frames
that contains some factors or
features of stocks, and it's arranged
in the usual way where each column
represents the value of the feature for
a particular stock.
And time goes downward essentially.
Now we might have many features for
each stock, for
instance we might have Bollinger Bands,
momentum, PE ratio, and so on.
We represent that by stacking
these one behind the other.
These are our X's.
What is our Y?
In most cases we want to
use our historical feature
data to predict a future price.
But to train our model, we're going to
use historical price as well.
So the value of these factors or
features today we call X and
we like to be able to run that
through the model that we've built and
get Y which is our
predicted future price.
Well, we don't have that model yet,
we've got to learn it.
And we've got to learn it from data.
So here's how we do that.
We roll back time so that we're back in
history here at our first data point.
We look at the values of our features
there, and then we look, say,
5 days into the future to see
what that future price is.
So now we've got a pairing of
these features with that future Y.
We save that XY pair into our data.
Now remember X can be multi-dimensional.
And that's one instance of data.
We move forward one day.
So we've got a new set of X's and
a new Y.
And we record that in our database.
Eventually, we reach a point
where we can't go any further
because there's no more Y data.
In other words, if we went one day past
this, Y would be out here in the future.
So we don't have that data to use, and
that means we've got some leftover data.
In any case, we now, for
each of these days in history, have
a pair of X's and Y's that we can feed
into our database to build our model.